[Music]
first let me lament the fact that we can
ask any one of us in any room I don't
care what age you are provided you
you're done with school and ask how many
teachers of all the teachers you've had
in life for most people that would be
like scores of teachers you know is it
seventy eighty a hundred teachers some
maybe as few as 50 or 40 but still in
the high tens ask among all your
teachers how many made a singular impact
in your life
how many changed you in fundamental
important ways unfortunately the answer
to that question is almost always no
more than this two three at most five
for me that numbers three and that's not
unusual so what is what gives here by
the way they wouldn't have to be science
teachers I'm talking my teachers in any
subject and what makes those teachers
special is that you could have no
interest in the subject going in and you
come out and it's the most interesting
thing you've ever heard in your life
those teachers convey something special
within their students enthusiasm and
excitement a passion so one of my great
laments is that education today seems to
have be less about passion and more
about process more about tactic or
technique uh but I don't know anybody
who said boy I love that teacher he or
she gave a really good homework set or
boy that was the best class I ever took
because those exams were awesome that's
not what people want to talk about
that's not what influences people in one
profession or another it's it's how well
the instructor imparted their passion
for their subject in their students and
just extend this to the sciences we all
know people who would turn off by
science because they had a bad teacher
that's the worst case the teacher the
teacher now had the opposite effect of
what education ought to be so I don't
know - do we rifle through the
educational system and like get rid of
those teachers and clone the others I
don't have an easy silver bullet there
but I do know but that shouldn't prevent
me from citing at least part
what the problem is I want to see more
impassion teachers than are currently
out there and if you can light a flame
in a student that's that's how half the
work
[Music]